este hospital de lyon está haciendo todo
lo posible para recibir el mayor número
de pacientes con kobe 19 pero está
extremadamente saturado a 52 camas en el
hospital y 23 están ocupadas por
pacientes con el logo coronavirus
tuvimos que liberar una cierta cantidad
de camas hasta el punto de que ahora
tenemos prácticamente la misma cantidad
que teníamos la primavera pasada cuatro
nuevas camas estarán disponibles a
finales de semana sin embargo la escasez
de personal es otra preocupación
importante salió se está volviendo
crítico porque estamos cansados y no
podemos conseguir el personal necesario
y son en todos los hospitales de la
región están ahora sobrecargados y la
única solución es llamar a trabajadores
de respaldo de otros servicios de
atención el 60 por ciento de los
trámites no urgentes han sido cancelados
y tenemos que cerrar los quirófanos para
que los cirujanos vengan a ayudarnos así
que a medida que liberamos camas
cerramos los quirófanos y sale un bloque
esta enfermera que trabaja habitualmente
en quirófanos se trasladó a la unidad de
reanimación hoy cuidado un paciente que
se encuentra en estado crítico
todos los días el hospital ve casos de
infección cada vez más graves como éste
estamos empezando a ver de nuevo lo que
vimos en marzo es difícil porque es un
trabajo muy exigente y no el personal
del hospital espera ver el impacto del
toque de queda de lyon en su carga de
trabajo pero la situación es muy
preocupante especialmente con el récord
de contagios que viene registrando el
país